what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and today we have really
great news coming directly from chris
hemsworth thor himself about him
returning for another thor film now
obviously thor love and thunder is about
to hit theaters in about two weeks and
fans have been wondering if this is
going to be the last thor film that we
get with chris hemsworth's thor we
wonder if chris is done because we have
a new thor coming to the mcu and thor
love and thunder jane foster's the
mighty thor but we have a little bit of
clarity about this today and we also
have some very interesting news about
the fantastic four that may not be good
news for everybody specifically news
about who was going to be playing mr
fantastic and i should state right away
we are going to be talking about
spoilers for multiverse of madness so if
you have not seen that yet you should
probably click away now if you are still
here the news of course is about john
krasinski possibly not playing the main
mr fantastic in art mcu and it might be
bad news but i'll break down exactly
what it means and what you need to know
in this video so if you're new be sure
to subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the latest mcu news alright so in
an interview with extra tv chris
hemsworth on the red carpet addressed on
his return to play thor for possibly
thor 5 and more and here's what he had
to say about playing thor after thor 11
thunder i have to ask you this because a
lot there's a lot of rumblings going on
about this is this going to be your last
time playing thor i love it i love it i
don't come back for more and more until
someone kicks me off the stage you know
i love it now i'm going to tie this to
something that kevin feige has recently
said but right away it's very clear that
chris hemsworth will pretty much play
thor until they tell him to stop that's
literally what he said so let's set the
record straight chris hemsworth wants to
continue to play thor he wants to
continue to be a part of the marvel
cinematic universe and i think a lot of
other people want him to stay in the mcu
as well especially since we don't really
have that many original avengers left
and who knows when the other ones are
going to be leaving now there could
actually be even more thor's joining the
mcu than just jane foster's thor and
chris hemsworth's thor which is a really
cool thought and this also kind of leans
more towards the fact that we'll see
chris hemsworth's thor again because
check out what marvel studios president
kevin feige had to say about the future
of the thor franchise in an interview
with slash film in this interview
discussion came around to the future of
the thor franchise and the possibility
of other thor's beyond jane and chris
hemsworth's character entering the mcu
in which kevin feige said there are
these things called comic books that
have a lot of stories in them and that's
where all of our stories come from and
if the question is have you told all of
the great horror stories from the comics
and movies the answer is no there are
lots of them and i've always said our
interest in making additional stories is
somewhat about continuing the character
it's almost entirely about continuing
the experience with the actor and being
able to see i think of all of our casts
not as their individual characters but
as the marvel players who within that
character can grow and evolve and change
and if we look at the comics as our
guide there are plenty of other
incarnations of thor that we have yet to
see now this is fantastic news for chris
hemsworth staying in the mcu but right
away what i actually think about when i
hear kevin feige say this or read what
he said is i automatically think of beta
ray bill when we think of other
incarnations of thor this is exactly
what i think of in my head in for
ragnarok they actually teased beta ray
bill they had a huge statue of his head
on sakhar in the colosseum right next to
where they were building the hulk statue
and in fact in avengers endgame marvel
confirmed in the scene where nebula is
fighting some people and gamora comes to
save her right before thanos calls them
to the ship they confirmed that the
planet that they were on was the home
world to the corbinites which is what
beta ray bill is so we've had a couple
of little teases for beta ray bill in
the mcu already and now kevin feige is
talking about other incarnations of thor
in the mcu i'm hoping that we see him
very soon and it does look like chris
hemsworth is not going to be done with
thor love and thunder he's going to
continue to play thor in the mcu based
off of what he said and what kevin feige
said in this interview chris said he'll
play until pretty much they make him
stop and kevin feige said that he looks
at the actors who play these characters
like thor as marvel players who within
that character can grow and evolve and
change so he's talking about chris
hemsworth here he's talking specifically
about chris hemsworth's thor so
according to kevin feige there's still
much more growth evolution and change to
be had with chris hemsworth's thor so
this is excellent news i think chris
hemsworth is going to be playing thor
for at least one more film thor 5 which
is kind of funny to talk about because
thor love and thunder isn't even out yet
but once you see thor love and thunder
you will definitely want chris hemsworth
to play in another thor film because
it's pretty fantastic now moving on to
some recent fantastic four news
specifically talking about john
krasinski as reed richards in doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness if
you caught my podcast yesterday which is
up on youtube it's also on apple music
and spotify you know that one kevin
feige actually confirmed a doom easter
egg kevin feige said that the technology
that reed richard uses to transport or
teleport himself into the illuminati's
headquarters in multiverse of madness
was based off of doom technology in the
comics so right away that's pretty cool
a dr doom easter egg in the mcu but
what's also interesting is that we
learned that kevin feige actually cast
john krasinski as this other alternate
universe mr fantastic because of the
fans the fans wanted john krasinski and
he thought well this is going to take
place in another universe here's our
chance to do that now a lot of people
are taking this in kind of a negative
way and i completely understand a lot of
people are taking this as well he only
cast krazynski because the fans wanted
it and he was putting him in another
universe which means he's probably not
casting him as the main mr fantastic
this was kind of a one-off opportunity
where he could put him in another
universe and it doesn't really matter
that much because it's not the main mcu
however keep in mind that some variants
do look the same yes some look different
like we learned in loki but loki also
taught us that some look exactly the
same and in fact multiverse of madness
taught us that as well because each
doctor strange looked like doctor
strange every doctor strange was played
by benedict cumberbatch so yes rmcu reed
richards mr fantastic could look
different or it could be john krasinski
because variants do look alike let's
also keep in mind that every variant
that we've seen so far the scarlet witch
looks the same so if multiverse of
madness is the basis for variance it
kind of tells us that the variants look
the same and that's where we saw john
krasinski so based off of the logic of
multiverse of madness john krasinski
still should be playing the main mr
fantastic in our earth 616 universe now
again that's not confirmed because like
i said there are different looking
variants like all of the peter parker's
but the logic from multiverse of madness
says that he should be the same heck
even mortal looked the same captain
carter looked the same black bolt
although black belt was never
technically in the mcu but you get it
and i think the most important part is
is how well did john krasinski do as mr
fantastic and i think the answer to that
is incredible i think he is mr fantastic
and marvel would be you know kind of
dumb if they let the opportunity slip by
for john krasinski to not be the main mr
fantastic but i think marvel realizes
that that's the move john kuczynski has
mr fantastic so i'm not too worried
about it but of course if i hear
anything else i'll be sure to let you
know asap so be sure to subscribe and
hit that notification bell so you don't
miss out on any of the latest breaking
news please don't forget to like the
video and for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof
me